schönen guten Tag zusammen ZDF heute
live hier wahrscheinlich fragt sich so
ziemlich jeder was in den nächsten
Monaten da noch auf uns zukommt die
Energiepreise explodieren vor allem für
Gas die Bundesregierung will
Verbraucherin Verbraucher und
Unternehmen entlasten mit insgesamt 200
Milliarden Euro wir erinnern uns O-Ton
Kanzler Scholz das sogenannte
doppelwummspaket aber die Frage ist ja
jetzt wie kann dieses Geld sinnvoll
verteilt werden und um diese Frage zu
beantworten hat die Regierung eine
Expertenkommission angesetzt die wird
jetzt gleich in wenigen Minuten um 10
Uhr vorstellen was Sie für den richtigen
Weg hält wir werden Ihnen und Euch diese
Pressekonferenz zeigen wir haben auch
einen Verbraucherschützer zu Gast Udo
Sieverding der auch sehr gerne Fragen
beantwortet apropos Fragen jederzeit
gerne auch Kommentare einfach in die
Chats schreiben oder eine E-Mail
schicken und jetzt ist uns aus dem
Hauptstadtstudio Berlin zugeschaltet sie
gibt uns eine Einschätzung wie das Ganze
politisch zu bewerten ist guten Morgen
hallo Nicole hallo guten Morgen Jessica
Nicole da ist heute morgen schon ein
bisschen was durchgesickert kannst du es
kurz für uns zusammenfassen genau also
mit aller Vorsicht in drei Minuten
fangen wir an mehr zu wissen das was
bisher durchgesickert ist ist ein zwei
stufen-modell das so aussehen soll dass
die Verbraucher im Dezember einen
monatsabschlag erstattet bekommen von
der Bundesregierung dann ab März oder
April ein Deckel gelten soll
das ist im Moment das was wir wissen
also zweistufig einmal erstatten weil es
wahrscheinlich auch einfach nicht
rechtzeitig funktioniert diesen
gaspreisdeckel zu installieren und dann
ab Ende Winter
eben diese Deckelung nach oben
wir können uns das gerade noch mal kurz
anschauen mein Kollege Thomas Gonser hat
das für uns zusammengefasst
die Expertenkommission schlägt ein zwei
stufen-modell vor in einer ersten Stufe
soll im Dezember ein monatsabschlag
erstattet werden Stufe 2 erfolgt so die
Empfehlung dann für private Haushalte
sowie kleine und mitteleunternehmen ab
März im nächsten Jahr ihnen soll mit
einem gaspreisdeckel von 80% des
vorjahresverbrauchs geholfen werden Höhe
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde für den
Verbrauch über 80% müssen Sie selbst
aufkommen all das soll 14 Monate gelten
Industriekunden bekommen schon ab Januar
Unterstützung sie sollen für 70% des
vorjahresverbrauchs einen gedeckelten
also festen Preis von 7 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde bekommen das so der
Vorschlag soll 16 Monate lang gelten
Nicole was würdest du sagen wenn das
dann tatsächlich auch so kommt hätte das
diesen angekündigten sogenannten
doppel-wummseffekt
es hat vor allem erstmal ein extrem
wichtigen Effekt nämlich dass endlich
mal Zahlen auf dem Tisch liegen und die
Leute die Verbraucher nicht mehr völlig
ratlos und auch mit großer Sorge auf die
nächste Abrechnung warten das ist das
eine und das zweite ist das war ja
vergangene Woche wir erinnern uns auf
einer sehr skurrilen
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die so gut
wie ohne Ergebnis weil eben noch nichts
vorlag zu Ende gegangen ist gefragt wo
ist denn der Anreiz zum Sparen und
dieses Modell wir haben ja gerade
gesehen 80 Prozent für private
Verbraucher 70 Prozent für die Industrie
das animiert ja dann schon zu sparen
wenn nur bis zu diesem Verbrauch eben
dieser Deckel gilt also noch mal es gibt
jetzt Orientierung es gibt konkrete
Zahlen aber bei aller Vorsicht auch wenn
genau das was wir gerade besprechen
jetzt gleich in knapp einer Minute
präsentiert werden sollte das muss ja
auch noch quasi durch die Politik das
ist ja damit noch nicht in Stein
gemeißelt und wir sehen gerade die
Bilder von der Pressekonferenz
vielleicht können wir sie mal ganz kurz
einblenden dass die Kameramänner schon
nach vorne gehen und sich aufgestellt
haben und insofern ist das immer ein
ziemlich gutes Zeichen dafür dass es
jetzt demnächst bald losgeht insofern
würde ich sagen schauen wir uns jetzt in
Ruhe diese Pressekonferenz an Nicole wir
sprechen dann gleich weiter vielen Dank
erstmal für den Moment
ja wir sehen hier gerade jetzt werden
erstmal noch mal ein paar Fotos gemacht
der Bericht wird in die Kameras gehalten
wir gehen mal davon aus dass es dann
vielleicht doch noch einen kleinen
Moment dauert der Zeit könnte ich noch
eine Frage an Nicole stellen wenn wir
sie noch haben da ist sie ja Nicole du
hast es eben kurz angesprochen das ist
nämlich ganz wichtig das sind in
Anführungszeichen erstmal nur Vorschläge
wie geht der Prozess dann weiter
also sprich heute dann auch noch über
diese Vorschläge über diese Ideen zu
beugen darüber zu beraten und dann
spielen die Ministerpräsidenten noch mal
eine Rolle ich habe es ja eben schon
gesagt die haben letzte Woche sich nach
ihrer MPK vor die Kameras gesetzt und
mussten im Grunde blank ziehen und sagen
wir haben hier noch nichts beschlossen
es geht ums Entlastungspaket Nummer 3
und auch davon hängt alles ab was jetzt
bei der sogenannten gaspreisbremse
beschlossen wird das heißt es wird jetzt
nach einigen Einigkeit gesucht da wird
hinter den Kulissen sehr viel
telefoniert werden was man letzte Woche
schon sagen konnte im Dezember könnte es
dann tatsächlich losgehen okay und jetzt
gehen wir nach Berlin in die
Bundespressekonferenz und schauen Sie
uns an danke für den Moment Nicole
verbracht haben hier schon sehr eng
verbunden waren auch zusammengesetzt
haben neben mir Herr Professor Siegfried
rußform Präsident des Bundesverbandes
der deutschen Industrie gefolgt von
Michael wassilidiad ist dem Vorsitzenden
der Industriegewerkschaft Bergbau Chemie
und Energie bei verschiedenen Energie
und Frau Professor Veronika Grimm
Mitglied der Sachverständigenrates der
Bundesregierung es geht um den
Zwischenbericht der
expertinnenkommission Erdgas und Wärme
und sie haben wenn ich das weiß richtig
was ein Zwischenbericht sind so an
Zwischenbericht gekommen
und es ist okay meine Damen und Herren
ja 35 Stunden intensive Gespräche liegen
hinter uns die haben wir auch gebraucht
heute morgen um 6:25 Uhr hatten wir dann
eine Entscheidung für den
Zwischenbericht der Zwischenbericht
erfüllt den Auftrag der Bundesregierung
sehr schnell und
in mindestens zwei Themenbereichen eine
gaspreisbremse zu formulieren und die
Architektur aufzuzeigen einmal für die
Haushalte und einmal für gewerblichen
industrielle Kunden wir haben uns bei
diesem bei diesem Zwischenbericht und
bei diesen Entwürfen von ein paar
Grundsätzen leiten lassen weil natürlich
viele Ziele
gleichzeitig erreicht werden müssen und
dazu braucht es Prioritäten und unsere
erste Priorität im Einklang mit dem
Auftrag der Bundesregierung war schnell
zu sein das konnte man auch daran
erkennen dass in diesem Punkt nämlich
der gaspreisbremse der Endzeitpunkt der
Erwartung dass wir etwas vorlegen auf
den heutigen Tag vorverlegt worden ist
das hat die Kommission natürlich auch
zeitlich gefordert aber der wichtigste
Punkt ist und das bitte ich auch bei dem
Blick auf die Ergebnisse zu beachten wir
wollten in der Entlastungswirkung
schnell sein wir wollten in der
Entwicklung des Modells und in der
Entlastungswirkung schnell sein und es
sollte spätestens zum Jahresende diesen
Jahres eine erste
Entlastungsmöglichkeit geschaffen werden
und dann in ein entsprechendes Modell
das über den Zeitraum der uns vorgegeben
wurde bis in Frühjahr 24 trägt das
zweite
ziel ist es sollte gerade für die
Haushalte aber auch für die Industrie
ein wirksamer Schutz vor der
finanziellen Überforderung die sich aus
der Preisentwicklung beim Gas ergeben
mit sich bringen und das dritte und das
hat ein gewisser Reibung nicht
Widerspruch aber Reibung zugleich
sollten natürlich auch
einsparanreize bleiben damit nicht eins
passiert dass wir am Ende die Gaspreise
senken und auch die sozialen Fragen
mildern aber die der Gasverbrauch
letztendlich nach oben geht denn die
Versorgungslage bleibt trotz der
gefüllten Speicher angespannt darüber
hinaus haben wir eine haben wir das ist
ja auch der Zeitraum für den doppelwumms
dass wir geblickt haben in dem gesamten
Auftrag bis in den Frühjahr
2024 das heißt wir haben jetzt nicht nur
themenbericht zwei Blöcke nämlich den
jetzigen Zwischenbericht und den
Endbericht den wir im Oktober vorlegen
wollen sondern wir haben auch zwei oder
anderthalb Jahre zu berücksichtigen zu
berücksichtigen wir haben uns
vorgenommen auch die Transformation
nicht in der Krise stoppen zu lassen das
heißt all das was wir tun soll auch
transformationsfragen berücksichtigen
die medialfall beschleunigen und ebenso
im Idealfall wollen wir natürlich dass
unsere Entlastungen auch bei der
Inflation sichtbar und spürbar wird das
ist zumindest ein zusätzlicher
Auftrag und letzter Punkt auch das ich
spreche jetzt aber vom zwischen- und
Endbericht also manche Dinge werden sich
erst im Endbericht wiederfinden wir
wollen natürlich das was Deutschland
hier tut auch im europäischen Kontext
denken dieser Bericht ist nicht gegen
Europa sondern in Europa für Deutschland
und die deutschen besonderen
spezifischen wirtschaftlichen sozialen
Themen so dass wir diese Fragen nicht so
verstanden wissen wollen dass in Europa
sozusagen ein eine Situation gibt in der
Deutschland vorweg läuft sondern wir tun
das was wir solidarisch in Europa immer
getan haben aber eben auch mit Blick auf
unsere Haushalte und Menschen ich selber
als derjenige der als Gewerkschafter in
der Gruppe sitzt freue mich über das
Ergebnis weil viele Forderungen die wir
auch erhoben haben sich wiederfinden und
welche das sind was ich wieder findet
das möchte ich jetzt durch meine
Kollegin meinen Kollegen vortragen
lassen und deswegen Veronika gesagt
bitte
sie haben das Wort ja vielen Dank
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die
Haushalte und die Unternehmen sind in
dieser Krise sehr stark belastet
besonders stark durch den Gaspreis der
ja massiv angestiegen ist und Stück für
Stück auch an die Haushalte und die
Unternehmen weitergegeben wird das
beginnt in diesem Winter rapide die
Verträge werden sehr sehr umfangreich
erhöht teilweise auf 20 25 30 Cent von
ursprünglich 7 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
und hier ist natürlich Schnelligkeit
geboten um diese massiven Belastungen
die die insbesondere die Gaskunden
treffen abzufedern und deswegen hat sich
die Kommission Gedanken gemacht wie
diese Entlastung eben in einem Tempo
gelingen kann die der Herausforderung
gerecht wird dass der Herausforderung
gerecht wird wir haben daher ein
zweistufiges Vorgehen vorgeschlagen und
zwar ist es in einer ersten Stufe
möglich die Gaskunden zu entlasten in
dem der Staat eine Abschlagszahlung und
die Abschlagszahlung im dezember 2022
übernimmt dadurch wird die Gasrechnung
um eine Abschlagszahlung entlastet das
ist ein sehr pragmatisches Vorgehen um
erstmal die Kostenbelastung für die
Menschen zu dämpfen das betrifft
diejenigen die direktkunde bei einem
Versorger sind direkt das betrifft aber
auch die Mieterinnen und Mieter die in
einem Mietshaus wohnen und die im Rahmen
der
Nebenkostenabrechnung ihre
Heizkostenrechnung bezahlen da ist es
allerdings so dass teilweise die
Abschläge noch gar nicht gestiegen sind
aber der Vermieter schon höhere
Gaspreise erfährt da wird diese Zahlung
auch die Liquiditätsprobleme der
Vermieter mit adressieren in einer
zweiten Stufe schlagen wir vor dass
tatsächlich eine Gas- und
wärmepreisbremse etabliert wird und zwar
ab März 2023 bis Ende April 2024 und in
dieser Zeit soll auf 80 Prozent eines
für den Verbraucher geschätzten
grundkontingenz eines Verbrauchs soll
der Preis auf 12 Cent abgesenkt werden
durch einen staatlichen Zuschuss so dass
der Abschlag jeweils in jedem Monat um
einen bestimmten Betrag sinkt den der
Verbraucher auch nicht zurückerstatten
muss das heißt man bekommt quasi jeden
Monat einen staatlichen Zuschuss auf die
Abschlagszahlung
so dass auf ein grundkontingent der
Preis auf 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
sinkt und das führt dazu dass einerseits
die Menschen entlastet werden der Preis
entspricht ungefähr dem Preisniveau dass
man in Zukunft erwarten wird es wird ja
nicht so sein dass der Preis in Zukunft
wieder auf 7 Cent runter geht wir werden
das russische Gas auf lange Zeit hin auf
Dauer nicht beziehen und deswegen wird
der Preis ja nicht wieder auf 7 Cent
runtergehen sondern er wird höher
bleiben höher bleiben und deswegen ist
eben das Ziel hier dieses new normal
sozusagen schon einzuführen aber eben
Anstiege über diesen Preis hinaus
auszubremsen
die Spar Anreize sind in diesem Modell
trotzdem voll erhalten wir sparen kann
profitiert auch voll davon dass erspart
weil er eben die hohen Gaspreise an der
Grenze außerhalb dieses 80% Kontingenz
dann einsparen kann also Gas sparen ist
ja ein ganz wichtiges Ziel aktuell wir
müssen in Deutschland ungefähr 20%
sparen um eine angespannte
Versorgungslage und eine
gasmangellage im Winter zu vermeiden und
insofern kombiniert dieser Vorschlag
eigentlich in einer guten Weise
einerseits das Ziel die Menschen zu
entlasten und auf der anderen Seite das
Ziel eben dass die Menschen Gas
einsparen das ganze schlagen wir vor
soll analog für Fernwärmekunden
etabliert werden da ist der Zielpreis an
anderer dass der Zielpreis bei 9,5 Cent
die Kommission hat diese Vorschläge in
sehr sehr kurzer Zeit beschlossen und
hat sehr intensive Gespräche geführt
gute Gespräche geführt und viele
Mitglieder aus der Wissenschaft und der
Praxis haben hier miteinander um die
bestmögliche Lösung gerungen dabei hat
natürlich wissenschaftliche Expertise
eine Rolle gespielt aber es hat auch das
Machbare eine Rolle gespielt es ging
darum mit Hilfe wissenschaftlicher
Expertise und der Expertise auch aus der
Praxis und der Belange aus der Praxis
der Herausforderungen auch der Menschen
die betroffen sind die bestmögliche
Lösung zu finden und die Kommission hat
hier glaube ich einen guten und vor
allen Dingen Machbaren Vorschlag
entwickelt damit gebe ich zu Siegfried
Russwurm weiter der die Vorschläge für
die Industrie erläutern wird
vielen Dank meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren guten Morgen auch von meiner
Seite Gas ist für die Industrie der
wichtigste Energieträger und für etliche
Branchen ein wichtiger Rohstoff durch
die aktuellen nie gekannten
Preissteigerungen stehen viele
Unternehmen unter massiven Kosten und
damit Wettbewerbsdruck für eine große
und weiter wachsende Zahl von Betrieben
ist diese Bedrohung existenziell es geht
aber nicht nur um das Schicksal
einzelner Betriebe und ihre
Arbeitsplätze sondern es geht um die
Leistungskraft und die Export Erfolge
der deutschen Industrie denn dies sind
Rückgrat der deutschen Wirtschaft wenn
dieser Erfolg auf dem Spiel steht dann
steht aber mehr auf dem Spiel als die
existenzärzlerbetriebe denn dann ist das
deutsche Wirtschaftsmodell gefährdet und
damit letztlich unser Wohlstand zum
Beispiel die Sicherheit unserer
Sozialsysteme
darauf hat die Bundesregierung in ihrem
Auftrag an die Kommission eindringlich
hingewiesen es gelte eine Gefahr für die
Stabilität unserer Volkswirtschaft und
für den sozialen Zusammenhalt abzuwenden
die Intensität unserer Beratungen
wortwörtlich bis heute zum Sonnenaufgang
entsprach der Tragweite dieser Aufgabe
und ich danke ausdrücklich meinen beiden
mitvorsitzenden und allen
Kommissionsmitgliedern und unseren
Körpers für ihre Beiträge ihre
Unterstützung die konzentrierte Arbeit
und ja auch die Ausdauer
letztlich die Nacht und ja wir haben
gerungen aber wir haben ein Ergebnis
erreicht dass wir für belastbar halten
und auf dieses Ergebnis kann die
Bundesregierung jetzt aufsetzen ist es
perfekt sicher nicht aber gibt es
Orientierungen die weiterhelfen davon
sind wir überzeugt aber klar ist auch
entscheiden muss die Politik wir konnten
nur Empfehlungen geben
zum Modell auch für die Industrie galt
die Prämisse entlasten und zugleich
weiterhin Sparanreize setzen
schon in den vergangenen Monaten hat die
Industrie ihren Gasverbrauch in
erheblichem Umfang reduziert zwischen 20
und 25 Prozent über die das ganze
Spektrum der Industrie hinweg die
Einsparungen wurden zum Teil durch
Effizienz und Prozessoptimierung durch
einen Wechsel des Energieträgers zum
Beispiel von Öl von Gas zu Öl aber
insbesondere auch durch eine deutliche
Reduktion der Produktionsvolumen
erreicht wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen
gerade Letzteres schmatzt den weniger
Produktion heißt weniger Wachstum
weniger Beschäftigung weniger Absatz
weniger Erfolg und auch weniger Steuern
und es ist zu befürchten dass sich
dieser Trend im kommenden Jahr fortsetzt
wir driften in einer Rezession auch
deshalb ist das Anliegen der
Bundesregierung die Belastung der
Industrie durch hohe Gaspreise zu
dämpfen richtig und gleichzeitig müssen
wir alle Hebel nutzen die konkret
drohende gasmangelage in diesem bitte
abzuwenden also weiter Anreize zum
gasparen zu setzen das ist eine
Gratwanderung einerseits sparenreize
aufrecht zu halten andererseits durch
gedämpfte Gaspreise Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
absichern Rezession bekämpfen und vor
allem Produktionsstandorte in
Deutschland zu sichern aus diesem Grund
schlägt die Kommission ein einfachen und
schnell umsetzbaren Mechanismus vor der
zum ersten Januar 2023 in Kraft treten
soll
maßgeblich war für uns den Prozess zu
einem new-norme der Gaspreise also einem
zukünftigen eingeschwungenen Zustand zu
führen und ganz generell die
Energiepreise in Deutschland für die
Industrie zu flankieren dieses new-norme
wird das haben man mit Kollegin mein
Kollege schon gesagt deutlich über den
Preisniveau vor dem 24 Februar 2020
liegen aber wir sind überzeugt auch
deutlich unter den aktuellen
Spitzenpreis werden wo genau das wissen
wir nicht wann wir es erreichen diesen
eingeschobenen Zustand wissen wir auch
nicht definitiv nicht in diesem Winter
vielleicht im Verlauf des Jahres 2024
wir haben also ein grundsätzlich zu
entlastenden Kontingent des
Gasverbrauchs eines jeden Unternehmens
definiert das Kontingent bemisst sich im
Regelfall an 70% des Verbrauches des
Jahres 2021 für den restlichen Teil das
Gasverbrauchs wird der volle vertraglich
vereinbarte Marktpreis fällig und
dadurch bleibt ein starker Sparer als
gesetzt eine mengenmäßige Obergrenze des
zu entlastenden Gasverbrauchs wird nicht
definiert da wir aufgrund der enormen
großen Größenunterschiede der
Unternehmen und der Bandbreite der
verbrauchten Mengen eine
diskriminierungsfreie Definition nicht
für möglich halten
auf dieses zu entlastende Kontingent
wird ein Beschaffungspreis der nicht zu
verwechselt ist mit dem Gaspreis
privater Verbraucher ein
Beschaffungspreis von sieben Cent pro
Kilowattstunde definiert und um die
Frage vorwegzunehmen die sieben Cent
Beschaffungspreis passen exakt zu den 12
Cent privatkundenpreis die geforderte
Gasmenge kann dann das verbrauchen der
Unternehmen für seine Zwecke nutzen oder
am Markt verwerten ja die Förderung ist
an den Standort Erhalt und eine
transformationsperspektive gebunden
Michael was sie alles hat das schon
erwähnt
die gewerte Subvention wird über den
jeweiligen Gaslieferanten organisiert
und dieser wird vom Staat
liquiditätsneutral mit den nötigen
Finanzmitteln ausgestattet für eine
Inanspruchnahme des Programms müssen
sich die Unternehmen bei ihrem Versorger
anmelden und müssen ihre Teilnahme
öffentlich machen
uns ist völlig bewusst meine Damen und
Herren ein onefits allansatz ist nie
völlig befriedigend kann es nie sein wir
sehen daher noch weiteren Bedarf zum
Beispiel für Härtefallregelungen für
spezifisch gelagerte Problemfälle die
der Standardmodell nicht abdecken daran
und einer Reihe weiterer technischer
Fragen der Umsetzung bei der Ziele also
nochmal Kostendämpfung und aufrecht
Erhaltung von sparanreizen wollen wir in
den kommenden Wochen bis zur Vorlage des
Abschlussberichts der Kommission noch
weiter arbeiten wir haben ja noch drei
Wochen Zeit dafür herzlichen Dank vielen
Dank Herr profum bevor wir bevor wir zu
fragen und Antworten der drei
Vorsitzenden kommen die Pressekonferenz
wird live in verschiedenen Sendern
übertragen der Zwischenbericht ist noch
nicht online wird aber im Laufe des
Vormittags online gestellt es sind noch
nach der Nachtsitzung leichter
redaktionelle Verschönerungen will ich
mal sagen nötig die werden jetzt gerade
vorgenommen und sie sind dann auf der
gas-kommission.de Seite zu finden oder
über das und die Seite des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums ich habe
ein gutes
soweit die Pressekonferenz der
Expertenkommission die eben Vorschläge
erarbeiten sollte wie dieses 200
Milliarden Entlastungspaket gut verteilt
werden kann wir konzentrieren uns
vielleicht auf die Privathaushalte
zunächst einmal da wurde jetzt ein
Vorschlag gemacht es geht um zwei Stufen
ich fasse es mal ganz kurz zusammen es
geht darum die Gaskunden zu entlasten
das im dezember
2022 der Staat quasi eine
Abschlagszahlung übernimmt und dann soll
es noch eine zweite Stufe geben die soll
dann andauern von März kommenden Jahres
so 23 bis April 2024 da wird
der der das der Gaspreis 80 Prozent des
grundkontingents bei 12 Cent gedeckelt
und das bedeutet alles was dann darüber
anfällt wird quasi auch vom Staat
übernommen und diese 12 Cent vor Jahres
also vor waren 7 Cent
das ist der Preis den die gaskommission
entwickelt ermittelt hat und wo sie
davon ausgeht dass der auch künftig
gelten wird also alles ein bisschen
kompliziert wir wollen es aufdröseln und
gehen erstmal zu unserer Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin Nicole Diekmann nach
Berlin
Nicole das waren ja die im Wesentlichen
die Vorschläge die jetzt heute morgen
schon kursiert sind
und wir halten fest das hast Du vorhin
schon gesagt das sind jetzt erstmal nur
Vorschläge letztlich entscheiden muss
die Regierung treffen diese Vorschläge
den politischen Nerv in Berlin genau es
ist erstmal nur ein Zwischenbericht wir
haben es gerade auch zum Schluss noch
mal gehört es gibt noch zwei weitere
Treffen dieser Kommission die Ende des
Monats den Abschlussbericht ihrer
abschließende Empfehlung vorlegen will
nächsten Montag und übernächsten Montag
trifft man sich noch mal trotzdem ist
das heute natürlich ein wichtiger Termin
ein wichtiges Signal und genau das ist
es die politische Stimmung soll damit
getroffen werden und ein Stück weit tut
sie es vor allem mit der schlichten aber
extrem wichtigen Tatsache dass jetzt
einmal ein Fahrplan auf dem Tisch liegt
dezember
2022 ist die erste Wegmarke und zahlen
nämlich 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde für
die ersten Prozent verbrauchten
Kilowattstunden Gas das heißt Menschen
die sich große Sorgen machen vor der
nächsten Gasrechnung bzw vielleicht auch
schon eine im Briefkasten hatten können
jetzt für sich erstmal kalkulieren wie
können sie durch diesen Winter kommen
und auch nicht ganz unwichtig dass new
normal wurde ja gerade mehrfach
angesprochen du hast das auch gerade
schon gesagt 12 Cent das sagten die drei
die da gerade oben auf dem Podium saßen
das könne so etwa der realistische
Gaspreis der Zukunft sein weil man auf
russisches Gas auch langfristig erstmal
nicht mehr zugreifen würde also auf 7
Cent pro Kilowattstunde das können wir
uns wahrscheinlich alle abschminken
wir schauen mal gerade im Chat wie diese
Vorschläge dort angekommen sind da
schreibt John Doe Beruhigungspillen und
Hinhaltetaktik nach der Deckelung kommen
die Steuererhöhungen
ja also dann würde mich kurz
interessieren was die Quelle seines
Wissens ist ich habe darüber keine
Kenntnis das ist jetzt erstmal nur eine
Annahme vielleicht auch Polemik
möglicherweise das Julia schreibt auf
Facebook ja Zwischenbericht das dauert
also noch ewig bis was beschlossen wird
und sie fragt wie lange dauert es bis
diese Vorschläge beschlossen werden also
da geht es jetzt tatsächlich um diese
konkrete Umsetzung dann naja es gibt ja
wie gesagt diese Wegmarke dezember im
Dezember soll die komplette
Abschlagszahlung die wir Endverbraucher
bekommen vom Staat übernommen werden bis
dahin müsste man dann soweit sein dass
eingetütet zu haben also nochmal die
Kommission die wir gerade gehört haben
in Teilen drei der Mitglieder trifft
sich noch mal am 17 und am 24 will Ende
des Monats ihren Abschlussbericht
vorlegen und hat sich heute morgen schon
eine Stunde vor ihrer Pressekonferenz
mit dem Bundeskanzler getroffen um halb
zehn ist man da wohl zusammen gekommen
hören wir das geht jetzt natürlich
seinen Gang man wartet jetzt in der
Politik natürlich nicht auf den 24
Oktober und kommt dann erst ans Arbeiten
sondern wird diesen Zwischenbericht von
heute man muss das immer wieder betonen
dass das erstmal ein Zwischenbericht ist
aber der natürlich auch die Zustimmung
aus der Ampel haben wird sonst hätte man
sich heute nicht vor die Presse gesetzt
der wird jetzt diskutiert werden
SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht hat heute
morgen im Morgenmagazin von einem
wichtigen Signal an die Menschen
gesprochen und davon am Vertrauen zu
schaffen siehst du das erreicht mit
diesen Empfehlungen
es ist ganz klar dass Rolf Mütze nicht
davon spricht das muss ja immer Ziel
jedes politischen Handelns sein zumal
schauen wir mal kurz einen Tag zurück
gestern in Niedersachsen gewählt wurde
und mit zunächst Partei da zwar
weiterhin den Ministerpräsidenten stellt
aber auch Verluste hingenommen hat
ob das jetzt das richtige Signal ist
dafür auch das wurde gerade zum Ende der
Pressekonferenz noch gesagt von
Siegfried Russwurm vom Verband der
deutschen Industrie da sind noch Details
auszuhandeln die wenn man genauer
hinschaut keine Details sind es gibt
eine
Einschränkung der Gewerkschaft Verdi da
hat man zwar auch diesen Vorschlägen die
wir eben gehört haben zugestimmt aber
man gibt zu Bedenken Härtefälle sein mit
dieser Idee noch nicht abgedeckt das
heißt es kommt jetzt auch darauf an wie
geht man mit solchen Fragen um
wie diskutiert man diese Fragen auch
innerhalb der Ampel gibt man da ein
geschlossenes Bild ab oder
ist man da öffentlich und wie schnell
kommt man da auf welche Antworten
vielleicht noch eine letzte Frage an
dich Nicole wir schauen noch mal auf
EU-Ebene es gab ja viel Kritik an
Deutschland von anderen
EU-Mitgliedstaaten Stichwort Alleingänge
inwiefern tragen diese Vorschläge dieser
Kritik jetzt Rechnung
also wenn man Michael Vassiliadis der
eben als erster gesprochen hat und
Vorsitzender der Industriegewerkschaft
bergbiochemie und Energie ist glauben
darf dann ist das ein solidarischer
Vorschlag das muss er sagen das ist das
Signal das ausgesendet werden muss in
die EU denn die Kritik ist tatsächlich
massiv Deutschland wirtschaftet hier in
die eigene Tasche Deutschland zuerst ist
die Fahrweise dieser Vorschläge die da
jetzt auf dem Tisch liegen dieses
sogenannten doppelwunsch ich glaube
nicht dass das was da eben präsentiert
worden ist jetzt diese Kritik zum
Erlöschen bringen wird die hat natürlich
weiter bestand
ganz lieben Dank Nicole Diekmann nach
Berlin und ich wünsche dir noch einen
schönen Tag bis bald tschüss danke
gleichfalls tschüss
und bevor wir zu dem Verbraucherschützer
jetzt gleich rübergehen hat uns Thomas
Gonser noch mal kurz zusammengefasst was
das denn jetzt konkret für Vorschläge
war
die Expertenkommission schlägt ein zwei
stufen-modell vor in einer ersten Stufe
soll im Dezember ein monatsabschlag
erstattet werden Stufe 2 erfolgt so die
Empfehlung dann für private Haushalte
sowie kleine und mittlere Unternehmen ab
März im nächsten Jahr ihnen soll mit
einem gaspreisdeckel von 80% des
vorjahresverbrauchs geholfen werden Höhe
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde für den
Verbrauch über 80% müssen Sie selbst
aufkommen all das soll 14 Monate gelten
Industriekunden bekommen schon ab Januar
Unterstützung sie sollen für 70% des
vorjahresverbrauchs einen gedeckelten
also festen Preis von 7 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde bekommen das so der
Vorschlag soll 16 Monate lang gelten
und damit gehen wir jetzt direkt rüber
zum Verbraucherschützer Udo Sieverding
nach Düsseldorf guten Tag schön dass die
Zeit für uns haben
hallo schönen guten Tag sie war denken
Sie haben die Vorschläge der Kommission
gehört vorab wie finden sie die
ich finde sie okay also das Glas ist
mehr als halb voll würde ich sagen weil
es ja eine extrem schwierige Aufgabe war
die vor der gaskommission lag
kurzfristig was zu machen was vor allen
Dingen auch den einsparanreiz erhält auf
der Strecke geblieben ist jetzt das
Thema soziale Gerechtigkeit es wird
jetzt allen geholfen das ist gut solange
genug Geld da ist wenn aber sich zeigt
das nicht genug Geld da ist weil die
Energiepreissteigerung einfach sehr groß
dimensioniert sind dann geht man noch
mal merken dass man gerade den
Bedürftigen die es am meisten nötig
haben noch zusätzlich helfen muss
was ganz viele Userinnen und User im
Chat rumtreibt ist das Thema Gas und das
ist eben nicht zum Beispiel um Öl geht
ich kann ja mal kurz ein paar Sachen
Vorlesen Chris WhatsApp schreibt nein
ähm Öl Sekunde Prince bin auch in einer
Mietwohnung mit Ölheizung wird es da
auch einen Deckel geben Helga fragt Öl
ist doch genauso teuer was ist damit
sie fragt wie verhält es sich mit den
Heizölpreisen die gehen ja auch durch
die Decke es ging ja jetzt tatsächlich
erstmal um Gas oder
genau es ging in dieser Kommission die
ja auch schon den Namen gaskommission
trägt ausschließlich um Gas ich bin noch
mal gespannt auf die Details wenn es um
die Fernwärme geht weil natürlich ein
Teil der Fernwärme in Deutschland auch
zum Beispiel mit Kohle
produziert wird erzeugt wird ob das mit
jetzt einbezogen ist oder ob das
wirklich nur auf Gas fernwärme ist ich
vermute dass auch Kohle und andere
Fernwärme Erzeugungsarten mit drin sind
aber in der Tat die ölkunden bleiben auf
der Strecke bislang es gab die ersten
drei entlastungspakete da war natürlich
für jeden ein bisschen was dabei aber es
gibt auch viele ölheizungskunden die
sich bei uns auch melden bei den
Verbraucherzentralen und genau darauf
hinweisen dass sie jetzt davon nicht
betroffen sind ich bin mal sehr gespannt
wie das jetzt in den politischen
Diskussionen weitergeht das dürfte ja
nicht nur uns auffallen dass hier eine
große Zielgruppe vergessen wurde
das sind jetzt alles sehr sehr
kurzfristige Lösungen zum Beispiel diese
Abschlagszahlung die jetzt schon im
Dezember kommen soll ist das überhaupt
realistisch dass das alles so schnell
realisiert werden kann
ich gehe davon aus weil die
Energiewirtschaft ja mit in der
Kommission gesessen hat dass dieser
Ausgleich über den Abschlag also einen
Monat den Abschlag aus die
Abschlagszahlung auszusetzen den den
Lastschrift Einzug oder wie auch immer
dass das durchgeprüft ist und dass das
deswegen auch machbar ist nicht oder
noch mal schwieriger wird ist bei
mieterhaushalten da bekommt dann zwar
der Vermieter eben das klang ja auch im
Beitrag von Herrn war es glaube ich
darauf hingewiesen hatte an dass dann
die Vermieter profitieren ob das dann
auch bei den mieterhaushalten ankommt
weil noch nicht bei allen aber bei dem
Teil sind eben die höheren Abschläge
auch schon angekommen das wird sich noch
mal zeigen aber es gibt sicherlich auch
noch weitere Details die jetzt in den
nächsten Tagen mal wenn man sich den
Bericht mal durchgesehen hat und vor
allen Dingen in was macht die Politik
damit
setze ihn eins zu eins um oder ich hatte
heute Herr Mütze nicht im Morgenmagazin
auch so verstanden dass ihm die soziale
Komponente sehr wichtig sei und das
würde bedeuten dass man das Paket noch
mal aufschnüren müsste genau dazu hat
unsere Kollegin man eben auch schon was
gesagt wir haben noch eine Frage auf
Youtube von Anonym sie schreibt sehr
krank zu Hause ist oder im Homeoffice
arbeitet der verbraucht ja mehr Energie
und ich nehme an dass Ihr Kommentar
darauf abzielt dass sie ja dann auch
anders entlastet werden müssen
ja wir halten grundsätzlich ja ein
anderes Modell für sinnvoller deswegen
bin ich auch mit der zweiten Stufe die
dann im März kommen soll mit dem Gas mit
der Grundpauschale nicht so richtig
zufrieden eigentlich wären pro Kopf
energiegeld besser gewesen was man dann
auch wirklich pro Kopf ausschüttet und
was man dann auch sozial noch mit
asozialen Komponente versehen kann
jetzt geht es dann letztlich doch sowohl
in der ersten als auch in der zweiten
Stufe mit der Gießkanne zu so wie ich
das bislang verstanden habe und das ist
ja nicht nur die Frage Krankheit sondern
das ist natürlich auch dann die Frage es
gibt nun mal
Einkommensgruppen bei den privaten
Haushalten aber auch in der Wirtschaft
die denen es ja immer noch recht gut
geht und so lang genug Geld da ist für
alle obwohl es muss ja auch irgendwie
dann unsere Kinder bezahlen aber
ansonsten wenn man sich konzentrieren
muss dann ist natürlich die Priorität
sollte die Priorität sein sich auf die
zu konzentrieren die es wirklich nötig
haben ob sie wenig Einkommen haben oder
ob sie
und krankheitsbedingten Verbrauch haben
das muss man dann sich im Detail
anschauen aber die Priorität sollte eben
sehr stark sozial geprägt sein
dieses Thema treibt wirklich viele um
Wolfgang Renner schreibt es gibt keine
Alternative zu konsequenter
Verbrauchsreduktion das bedeutet vor
allem eine temperaturreduktion überall
ansonsten gibt es eine Staats- und
Privatschulden Katastrophe Plata fragt
wie soll das gegenfinanziert werden und
Ben das ist vielleicht eine Frage die
Sie beantworten können fragt wie soll
das bei Mietern funktionieren wo die
Vermieter die Abschläge zahlen in
Mehrfamilienhäusern
genau hatte ich ja schon darauf
hingewiesen das ist eine der offenen
Fragen genau dieses Mieter
vermieterverhältnis bei vielen
Haushalten ist es so dass die
Nebenkostenabrechnungen ja oder generell
die Nebenkostenabrechnung werden immer
Folge ja völlig und die Frage ist ob die
Energiepreissteigerungen jetzt aus 2022
von den Vermietern überhaupt schon
weitergegeben wurden wenn die da auch
noch nicht weitergegeben wurden die
Abschläge noch nicht erhöht wurden dann
kann sich jetzt in der Tat der Vermieter
erstmal das Geld einstecken muss und das
dann nachher mit der nächsten
Nebenkostenabrechnung verrechnen wenn
Mieter jetzt schon deutlich höhere
Abschläge zahlen dann wäre es natürlich
sinnvoll Ihnen jetzt auch im Dezember
das Geld unmittelbar zurückzugeben
das wäre dann in dieser in diesem Fall
sinnvoller
es gibt noch ein kleines bisschen
Verwirrung um diese zweite Stufe
vielleicht können wir die noch mal
aufklären da gibt es auch eine Frage
beziehungsweise ein Kommentar von
Benjamin Prüßner auf Youtube er schreibt
lustig erst ab März der Deckel bedeutet
dieser Winter wird teuer und die 12 Cent
Deckel bringen mir nichts ich bezahle
trotz Erhöhungen nur 19 bedeutet für
mich ich muss dann mehr zahlen aber es
geht ja darum dass die Kommission einen
Preis angenommen hat der in Zukunft
gelten wird
genau also da kann man dem
Fragensteller da nur
gratulieren dass er noch 19 bezahlt auch
wenn das schon zum im Vergleich zum vor
Krisen Niveau ja möglicherweise 50%
Aufschlag ist aber viele Haushalte
Zahlen schon das drei oder vierfache bei
uns man Verbraucherzentralen melden sich
viele die schon 20 Cent oder 25 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde zahlen das ist keine
Seltenheit mehr teilweise auch in der
Grundversorgung geht es deutlich über 15
Cent und da ist natürlich der Deckel auf
12 Cent sinnvoll und spürbar auch aber
klar es werden nicht alle davon
profitieren aber das ist eben genau die
Schwierigkeit und auch das Problem und
wie gesagt es ist auch keine soziale
Priorität bei diesen 12 Cent
es sei denn es sind ja noch ein paar
Wochen und der Endbericht steht ja auch
noch aus dass da noch mal nach gesteuert
wird
und noch eine letzte Frage aus dem Chat
otonose keilfragt und was wenn du nicht
mehr sparen kannst und das Geld reicht
trotzdem nicht
genau das ist ja genau das Problem auf
dass wir immer Hinweisen jetzt gibt es
ja noch die Überlegung
wohngeldausweitung mit
Heizkostenpauschale und es gibt auch die
Möglichkeit das ist nicht sehr populär
aber es gibt zumindest die die
Systematik dafür wer dass die
Energiepreise überhaupt nicht mehr
bezahlen kann oder in dem Monat wo zum
Beispiel die große Nachzahlung oder
Schlussrechnung kommt das einfach in
diesem Monat nicht bezahlen kann weil
sich das aufgetürmt hat der könnte auch
oder die für diesen Monat dann ALG2 also
Hartz IV beziehen das schreckt natürlich
schon bei dem Begriff viele ab aber es
ist immer noch besser als in die
Schuldenspirale abzudriften und hier
sollte man sich rechtzeitig erkundigen
und vielleicht noch letzte Frage an Sie
ja sie werden was muss man jetzt machen
als Verbraucherin als Verbraucher als
gastkunde wie kommt das Geld jetzt zu
einem konkret
also wichtige Botschaft ist jetzt auch
heute des Tages erstmal gar nichts
machen man kann sich zu Hause voll aufs
Energie sparen konzentriert jetzt in der
Heizperiode und dann muss ja zunächst
mal die Bundesregierung sich jetzt zu
diesem Zwischenbericht äußern dann muss
das wenn es wirklich auf diese
abschlagszahlungsübernahme im Dezember
das muss dann von den Energieversorgern
ja alles umgesetzt werden die Kunden
werden das dann schon früh genug noch
erfahren und im besten Fall bekommen Sie
einfach eine Rückerstattung aufs Konto
oder eine Verrechnung dann mit dem
Januar das wird man alles sehen wie die
Details hier aussehen auf jeden Fall
aktiv werden wir haben 20 Millionen
Gaskunden in Deutschland Haushalte die
können jetzt nicht alle zu ihrem
stadtwergrennen und da die Kundenhotline
lahmlegen sondern erstmal abwarten
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie
uns so viele Fragen beantwortet haben
vielen Dank tschüss
sehr gerne schönen Tag
und dann sprechen wir jetzt zum Schluss
noch mit der energieökonomen Claudia
Kempfert vom Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung
guten Tag hallo guten Tag schön dass sie
sich kurzfristig Zeit für uns nehmen
konnten wir haben jetzt dieses
zweistufen-modell zum einen irgendwie
diese Abschlagszahlung im November und
zum anderen die Deckelung auf 12 Cent
wie würden sie das bewerten ist es für
Sie das richtige Signal
ja grundsätzlich finde ich es ein
richtiges Signal dass man suggeriert
oder auch Vorschläge arbeitete wie jetzt
die Kosten gedeckelt werden können darum
muss es ja letztendlich auch gehen das
Kosten gedeckelt werden dass man
Privathaushalten hilft und auch der
Wirtschaft ich bin nach wie vor sehr
skeptisch was auch die Vorschläge angeht
mit der Einmalzahlung mit der
Pauschalzahlung kann ich mitgehen das
halte ich auch für sinnvoll dass man da
jetzt entsprechend
unterstützte was die gaspreisbremse
angeht bin ich nach wie vor sehr
skeptisch und zwar aus dem Grund dass
wir wirklich gucken wir müssen das mehr
Gas eingespart wird ich sehe hier nach
wie vor die große Gefahr dass nicht
ausreichend gespart wird wenn jetzt den
Menschen suggeriert wird naja ihr zahlt
jetzt eh nur irgendwie 12% pro
Kilowattstunde die Preise liegen
deutlich drüber an sie sind eben auch
knappheitspreise das heißt wir haben
Angebots Knappheiten und die Sorge habe
ich nach wie vor ich hätte es besser
gefunden man macht eine
pro-kopf-energiepauschalen irgendeiner
Richtung damit man hier auch
entsprechend entlastet und vor allen
Dingen auch sozial gestaffelt so ist es
sehr stark mit der Gießkanne man gibt
auch viel Geld für Haushalte die es
nicht so stark nötig haben sondern dass
man mehr da drauf sich konzentriert
hätte sozial Schwache Haushalte zu
entlasten und das auch zu schaffen
vielleicht macht man das ja auch noch
politisch das wäre zumindest meine
Empfehlung dass man da noch eine
stärkere soziale Komponente einbaut und
auch bei der Wirtschaft eher noch mal
schaut ob man nicht doch in Richtung
Prämien geht für das sparen weil wir
müssen mit dem Verbrauch runter sonst
wird der Winter wirklich kritisch
diese Sorgen macht sich auch Florian
Heuser auf Youtube er schreibt die
Gasspeicher sind sowieso ab Weihnachten
leer das Erzählen die nur nicht also da
machen sich tatsächlich einige Gedanken
darüber verstehe ich sie richtig dass
ihnen gerade in Stufe 2 dieser einspar
Anreiz nicht stark genug ist
ja genau der Einreise ist mir da nicht
stark genug wir brauchen irgendeine
Komponente dieser sparen belohnt und ich
wenn man Geld gibt das ist ja enorme
Gelder die hier im mobilisiert werden es
wahnsinnig teuer die Gaspreise auf das
Niveau zu deckeln weil sie am Markt eben
so viel drüber sind wenn man das Geld
schon ausgibt dann sollte man das
gezielt für sparen geben weil so Köln
ist die Gefahr dass wir in Knappheit
Situationen im Winter hineinlaufen das
sollte man nach Möglichkeit vermeiden
deswegen hielte ich es für sinnvoller
dass man da tatsächlich eher in die
Richtung geht das Sparen zu zu mir an
irgendeiner Form auch tatsächlich zu
kompensieren oder zu belohnen
sehr viel den Fokus auf die privaten
Haushalte gelegt schau mal vielleicht
noch mal auf die kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen inwiefern werden die
entlastet durch diese Vorschläge
ja die werden schon auch entlastet wenn
es darum geht dass man Gaspreise deckelt
das wird in der Summe ja sowieso enorm
teuer das heißt aber auch das
Unternehmen entsprechend entlastet
werden auch kleinere und mittlere und
noch mal also noch besser wäre es man
würde da auch zielgerichtet vorgehen
dass man nicht die Preise Deckel sondern
deren Kosten damit der Verbrauch runter
geht und wir in keine
knappheitssituation im nächsten Winter
kommen jetzt schreibt irgendwie surfacts
auf Youtube hätte mal wesentlich mehr
verbraucht dann würdest du sie jetzt
besser dastehen was die Erstattung
angeht also er spielt auf diese
Abschlagszahlung im Dezember an geht
aber insofern ja nicht auf die Rechnung
weil Gas Spanier angesagt ist
ja das gasparen ist angesagt aber der
Punkt ist hier schon auch da
dass man tatsächlich eben nicht
ausreichend das Sparen auch unterstützt
dass diejenigen die eben dann viel
verbraucht haben dann auch weiterhin das
können und wir dann eben auch in dieser
Gefahr laufen dass wir nicht ausreichend
einsparen unter sparen auch nicht
ausreichend unterstützt wird also dass
das ist die große Gefahr eben bei dieser
Deckelung des Preises da wäre es in der
Tat sinnvoller gewesen man würde da eher
Prämien geben Geld geben um zu sparen
weil viele müssen es ja tun und gerade
die Einkommen schwachen Haushalte können
hier auch zielgerichteter entlastet
werden wenn wir jetzt nicht so mit der
Gießkanne vorgehen würden sondern
wirklich zielgerichtet an die Haushalte
die auch tatsächlich den Bedarf haben
und darum muss es gehen
und es gibt trotzdem bei vielen noch die
Sorge dass auch das nicht ausreichen
wird Julia schreibt mal sehen ob ich es
schaffe die Heizung den ganzen Winter
auszulassen anders kann ich mir das gar
nicht leisten jetzt ist es natürlich
irgendwie schwer vorstellbar den ganzen
Winter nicht zu heizen über diese
Vorschläge hinausgehend was können die
Menschen tun das kann natürlich nicht
sein also Julia muss da ja geholfen wer
anders gibt es auch Einmalzahlung dass
da auch entsprechend Geld fließt
deswegen wäre auch eine pro Kopf so ein
pauschalgeld was ja auch kurzfristig
gezahlt werden kann weil man die nicht
Mechanismen dafür hat sinnvoller gewesen
dass jetzt niemand mehr heizen kann dass
es tatsächlich vollkommen nicht also das
sollte man auf jeden Fall vermeiden wir
sind in einem reichen Land und müssen
denjenigen wirklich helfen die sich das
nicht mehr leisten können das ist ganz
ganz wichtig und deswegen sollte man da
auch tatsächlich zielgerichtet vorgehen
und klar das
Haushalte die eh schon ganz sparen nicht
noch mal mehr sparen können ist klar
aber wir haben auch einen großen Bereich
von Haushalten aber auch Unternehmen die
deutlich mehr sparen könnten und es
jetzt nicht tun und das ist die große
Gefahr dass wir dann eben in eine
Versorgungsknappheit hineinlaufen eine
solche Deckelung des Preises kann die
Verknappung verschärfen und damit haben
wir die Gefahr dass wir in Knappheiten
im Winter hineinlaufen vielleicht
könnten sie zum Schluss noch mal
zusammenfassen was aus ihrer Sicht jetzt
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
passieren muss
ja es sollte auf jeden Fall eine sozial
ausgewogene Entlastung gegeben dass man
niedrig Einkommensbezieher stärker in
den Blick nimmt dass man nicht mit der
Gießkanne vorgeht dass man wenn man die
Kosten entlasten will gerne auch über
eine Pauschalzahlung geht die dann auch
Steuer versteuert werden muss damit
Einkommen starke Haushalte nicht für
vorteilt werden aber niedrig
Einkommensbezieher müssen stärker
entlastet werden das andere ist dass wir
eher darauf gehen sollten Prämien zu
zahlen für das sparen denn aktuell ist
es eben so dass nicht ausreichend
gesparte wird wir in dem Winter aber
Einsparpotenziale benötigen und sonst
eben Knappheiten haben also da noch mal
zu überlegen ob man es die nicht doch
noch mal kombiniert mit Prämien für das
Sparen gerade was auch Unternehmen
angeht oder auch Haushalte dass wir
diese Knappheiten vermeiden
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für Ihre
Antworten und wünsche auch Ihnen noch
einen schönen Tag danke Ihnen auch einen
schönen Tag alles Gute ja und auch Ihnen
und Euch ganz ganz lieben Dank für die
vielen Fragen und Kommentare ich hoffe
wir konnten so gut wie alles davon
klären und auch Ihnen und Euch noch
einen schönen Tag bis bald tschüss